he is a big-time comic actor produced
directed co-wrote and stars in the
interview opening Christmas Day Seth
Rogen is over here
like a Jew you clean up some political
show yeah yeah look I read saying are
you I know you dropped out of high
school I did I am both American and
Canadian and I am stupid
so I speak from both sides of the fence
here yeah stupid I'll get you a hardly
stupid you're quite rich now you were
you were right here on our set only a
few months ago it seemed like it was
this year because I filmed a little
piece in your movie yes you play Bill
Maher I've got a great movie career
people come to me and it takes me a half
hour yeah it's a pretty good gig and
you're in there and you get to play
yourself I get to leave your own office
it seems like a pretty dope big I have
to tell you the premise of this movie is
kind of genius because the premise is
you know we have dictators in the world
that America would love to get rid of
but you know we're not allowed to
actually officially assassinate them and
also how do you get close to them it
would be hard and your answer is who are
the one people who get close to them
journalists journalists yeah the movies
about we me and James Franco have like a
tabloid kind of celebrity talk show and
we find out that Kim jong-un is like a
big fan of our show and so we get an
interview with him and then the CIA
asked us to assassinate him basically
while we're interviewing him and we
agreed to do it and to try to do it real
I mean this is the real Kim jong-un in
the movie we didn't get him to play
himself
but it's not a guy who's like playing a
a closely-guarded virgin no in the movie
his name is Kim Jong right and an actor
is playing Kim jong-un the dictator of
right North Korea yeah and what would be
really great is that I've heard North
Korea has already taken the bait and is
objecting to this yes
great press great press yeah killed you
or tried to I know I hope they kill
Franco and not me personally but but
we're preferable but yeah they called it
an act of war and got an act of
terrorism which is a comedian is like
what you're [ __ ] looking for huh you
know I want to talk a little about Kim
Jong uh because some of your audience
probably doesn't even know what that is
Kim jong-un yes I don't follow the news
do you worry about that no we actually
did research to see if our audience knew
who Kim jong-un was and they
overwhelmingly did know who I was which
was pretty remarkable which kind of is
one of the reasons we made the movie
again like I'm not that savvy with
what's happening politically but I was
really into North Korea because it's so
[ __ ] weird it is and it just kind of
captures your imagination how bizarre it
is well I mean one reason I'm interested
in is because as an atheist I hear all
the time people say to me oh you know
what Bill you blame all the wars on
religion you know a lot of the violence
comes from people who are atheist like
Mao and Stalin and I always say that's
not really an accurate thing to say
because what Mao and Stalin did was made
the dictator yeah God exactly and Kim
let me give you some in facts about Kim
jong-il who was Kim jong-un's father
yeah just to show my point they tell the
people that he was born during a double
rainbow yeah I don't even know what that
is
they're awesome hey we'll get to the
stoner stuff later but uh there was a
glowing new star appeared in the heavens
during his birth which caused winter to
change to spring global warming yeah he
Kim jong-il learned to walk at the age
of three weeks look at giraffe that's
impressive
yeah that's really yeah when he was in
college he wrote 1,500 books over a
period of three years and six full
operas I think they are better than any
music in history eat that Taylor Swift
yeah um the first time he picked up a
golf club he thought he shot a thirty
eight under par yeah you know all these
are right yeah we did a lot of you yes I
know that's like trading oven holes in
one it's all true
like they actually say don't believe all
this [ __ ] my favorite Kim's official
biography and web sites claim that he
did not defecate yeah that's in the
movie that's in the movie on that one
and and he said to say about Kim jong-un
that's clearly something we gravitated
toward I've heard your [ __ ] doesn't
stink exactly I've never heard that you
don't actually don't [ __ ] and it made us
wonder does he have a butthole yeah and
if so what does it do
well I smell a sequel there exactly yeah
all right so let's talk about the fact
that one thing we have in common is we
were both named stoner of the Year by
high times Meg we were young white sand
uh
I certainly hope we don't have to
compete for that title again I hope not
yeah that was a rough year the smear
campaigns and I think we would argue
that that marijuana which has a
reputation for making people lethargic
make some people better yeah did you say
that you owe your career to the thoughts
you've had from marijuana maybe
I've had a lot of them while I was high
on marijuana
I can't definitively say I would have
had them if I wasn't but I had a lot
more fun having them when I was it yeah
I mean it makes me much more okay with
working honestly like I think like when
you smoke weed and work it makes working
much more enjoyable and therefore I work
a lot more than I would if I was waiting
to go home and smoke weed after I work
you smoke in the day yeah it's a work in
it's in a work incentive ah no it's a
work uh you know fuel I think it fuels
the fire uh in some ways it makes it
that I just don't care that I'm working
who wants to work the lower stone yeah
well I'm not you're lucky that you're in
a job that allows you to be stone yes a
lot of people get drug tested and [ __ ]
and uh yeah and that's and that and
their work doesn't lend itself to being
stone if you drive a truck or a nurse or
something then yeah I don't recommend it
right okay all right all right go but
every other job